(opening door)
(loud clap)
(scooting chair)
- I can't stop listening
to Chance The Rapper.
- It's a great album.
You know what I love about it?
I listen to it, I didn't
have any expectations
and I was like, "Wow, this feels a
lot like the first time I
listened to Kanye's first album".
I didn't know he was from
Chicago, so that was interesting.
- Yeah.
- You know what else it gives
me a little bit of a vibe of?
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I'll take a latte too, please.
- A latte, of course.
- A little Frank Ocean,
there's like a little,
there are some parts that makes
me feels like, like when he talks.
- Yeah.
- There's a talking, there's a talking
version of rap that I really
like, that I've noticed.
- I usually.
- Biggie did it like
I like the guy's talk.
- People are saying, "Oh, they
finally bit him in the ass".
It's like, no, the whole
reason they're here
is because of him,
you know what I mean?
It's a big part of what
makes them, them.
This is the trade off.
- Treymon just a
basketball version of me.
- It's actually very, very true.
- And, it's really how I play basketball.
I, you know, I'll kick anybody.
- Yeah.
- And, have no problem
with it, like I'm sorry.
It just is what it is.
It's just how I play.
- Right.
- I'm just not talented or humongous
or amazing but I'm a dirty player.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- I understand it.
It's competitiveness slightly off
kilter to the wrong direction.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- But, without it, all the
other good doesn't happen.
- [Marcus] Right.
- We need some real
basketball this morning.
- Ball in.
(yelling men)
(bouncing ball)
(squeaking shoes)
(yelling men)
I just wanted to hang.
- No, this is great actually.
- [Voiceover] We do have to go packs.
- Hello.
- Hey Gary.
- Have a seat.
- How are you?
(scooting chair)
How's it going?
- Good.
- I'm on a continuous quest to
try and spend more
time with people
from your organization and so
Jeff and I were
having a meeting,
I was like, hey, listen,
do me a favor
and put together
a small group
to have breakfast with and we
can shoot this shit and say
hey and talk about stuff
and maybe give
you guys a little access
in this kind of
environment to like,
for me to answer anything
that might be on your mind.
So, that's really it, nothing too crazy.
- Predictions for right now.
- Slack.
I actually like yours the best.
I just think there's like
a good diversity to it.
Do you play Candy Crush?
- [Woman] Yeah.
(laughter)
- Do you have a life?
I'm just kidding.
(laughter)
- I love it.
- You know what's
interesting about us
as a collective, this is the
first time I've seen this.
This is probably the least amount
of folder use I've ever seen.
- I thought it interesting that I'm the
only one using a folder for all my social.
- I have it, I have it.
- No one else has that.
- I've second.
- But, you have Snap out.
- So, look at this, the
first thing you know.
Actually this one's
folder back, this, yeah.
Who's is this?
- That's mine.
- So, you're really
like, and if you notice,
it's within your thumbs reach.
So, you're actually living just here.
So, I think the other
interesting thing is
this is a lot of what people do.
This is the weirdest fucking thing.
- I have huge hands.
- That's true, it does make
it better in your hand.
- Mines like, these are
the ones I use the most.
- Who's is this?
- That's mine.
My second new iPhone.
- Oh, so you also left the first of all.
- Yeah.
- Oh wait a minute, wait
a minute, wait a minute.
Yeah, this is your first screen.
Okay, wait a minute.
We have some dirty data.
- Yeah, look at this.
- My first one, I just.
- Everyone didn't clean their
first screen which I find odd.
- Oh.
- You don't clean your first screen?
- I use my second and third screen.
- Yeah.
- I find that so interesting.
It's like, oh, I can't touch this,
I'm gonna move to the second page.
John literally, I think he goes
to prison if gets any of this.
(laughter)
- This to me, is like the typical
I'm under 25, like music, SnapChat, Uber,
I live in New York, Maps, this is like.
- Super basic, no folders.
- Yes.
- And, I don't update my apps very often.
I still have the old Instagram.
- Seriously?
- I know, it's really bad.
- Actually, I actually think Instagram
is in a weird, vulnerable position.
I don't like how they're
getting squeezed right now.
Between SnapChat and Facebook.
Facebook has its
generation and SnapChat
is eating up too much
of what Instagram had.
The Apple Google war is the
most interesting one in tech
from the stand point of, I actually
think Apple can very
much hurt Google.
- Absolutely, that's a major search
engine, and a billion dollars.
- If they do real hard core ad locking.
Like Apple doesn't care
about banner ads.
iAds and that shit,
that's nothing.
- They killed it.
- Right but for, for
them to kill all banner
in this environment
really hurts Google.
So, that dance is
interesting to me.
What I think is more interesting
is how nobody here
in the business world
understands that there
is no other debate.
The only debate is
mobile and the only sub
debate is will it be
app consumption or
browser consumption?
In a world where
everybody here is still
doing business in
a desktop mentality.
That's what's interesting.
Thank you guys.
- [Voiceover] Thanks a lot.
- The number one thing
that I wish would happen
in the tech business world is
Facebook producing
an actual television.
It's my dream that Facebook
gets into the hardware business,
makes a television, so that
we can then take the content
from our feeds and throw
them right on the TV.
Your feed is connected
to your TV and
I just really think
Facebook would win.
I think controlling the hardware's
more important than people realize.
I think it's a very logical and
important move for Facebook.
So, that's it.
(music by Matt Reeves)
- [Man] So, are you filming
everything these days?
Are you happy with it?
Is it invasive or
are you okay with it?
- No, I'm super cool
with it, it's super cool.
Could you imagine watching your
great grandfather right now?
- It'd be crazy.
- Like, that's what
people don't understand.
I'll take the short term
heat of people like,
you're narcissistic,
you're a fucking idiot,
you're this,
whatever and I'm like, cool.
First of all, it's the same shit.
All of you are gonna do it.
A hundred percent of it.
- You're gonna have
another five years
of material without
anybody catches onto it.
- I don't believe it.
- Nobody's created a
tag video where you
create one take and
then let them all tag
to their friends and
fans so they can
basically pull in a
final piece that's
a combination of your content,
your content, my content.
I wanna see a
world in which like
Justin Bieber creates a
take of his first video.
- [Gary] What's the
matter with this guy?
I feel like he just
scheduled a normal meeting.
I feel like 10:30 just got scheduled.
- [Man] India's out there too?
- What was that?
I hope that was something good.
What was that?
- [Man] He's pumped
about it man.
- Just a normal 11:30
July 7th meeting booked?
Yep, alright.
- [Gary] I just
wanna have a conversation
where it's not about your idea
or how you're going to
raise your next round.
Like it's just, it's hard.
It's hard to have a
conversation with somebody
that want's to talk
about their business.
They're all doing that
because it's commoditized.
They're not building anything,
they're playing LTV and Cack 'til
the fucking cows come
home and they're
not building any real brand and
then the market changes
on them because
Pinterest gets expensive
and they're out of business.
I don't know, it's just feels like there's
a lot of, there's a lot of opportunity
for the people that we really
know what they're doing.
But way too much of, we all of us,
have created in the last decade a
financial arbitraged north star
not a build a business north star.
- [Man] Interesting.
Like growth at all costs.
- Series A at all costs, Series B.
They will reverse engineer you.
That's what they're doing,
they're trying
to figure out what metric,
or what thing
is going to make you click
to lead the next thing.
And, then all the
behavior goes there
even if it's at the peril
of the actual business.
The reason we've
been able to do that
is because more money
has been pumped in.
When there's not,
it gets really nasty.
Like real companies are gonna go
out of business, like big ones.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like big ones.
- This early?
- Yeah, you've got a long day
and I don't want you eating
up so you gotta eat this.
Come on.
At the very least, the protein in it.
- Fuck.
I just ate four seconds ago.
- How often are you doing this?
- Every day.
I mean right now.
- Trainer and chef.
- That's health CMO.
That's the chief health officer.
- You gotta be able to not ever.
- Oh, I'm in a crazy
place like heath wise.
- Yeah, you look great.
- Yeah, I'm like in a
totally different place.
- You okay, you're rest
and shit, you're busy.
- I'm busy as fuck but.
- But, this is your love,
your passion, all that shit.
- Everyone thinks
I'm crazy right now.
Only cause, no,
no, busy, it wasn't
SnapChatting and
DailyVee before and nobody
really realized how hard
I was really working.
- [Man] That's crazy how things
that get inside are like
you're actually moving quick.
- That's a very good point, speed.
I'm in the happiest second
of my life right now.
- Fuck yeah.
- I'm being dead serious.
Good to see you.
- You too.
That's solid, the salad face.
(opening door)
- If I'm gonna eat at fucking 10:30
this early after breakfast,
give me
a heads up so
I can tell you something.
I would eat sushi now in four
seconds but I can't eat this.
- You eat sushi now?
- Yes.
Go downstairs and get me sushi.
(laughter)
- Thank you.
- Very Japanese.
(laughter)
- Thank you.
- Some protein is easier
to consume than others.
- There you go,
that's all you need to do.
- I just got to communicate
to you what it is.
Like sushi, I told you
that the other day.
Salad sometimes
becomes so daunting to me.
- That's good to know, alright, perfect.
- But, sushi is has struggled
to ever become too much
and I feel like there's more protein.
I mean, you can map it out.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's a lot easier for me
to consume all this protein.
Like, this took, I'm already done.
- Yeah, perfect, thank you.
This helps a lot.
- Cool.
Huge announcement time coming
shortly, check my twitter.
- What's up?
(laughter)
How's it going?
- What's up buddy?
- I postponed some things because
Gary called me and said
we have an announcement.
- An announcement.
- And, I said that this better be
good and it turned out, it is.
You are announcing that you
are starting a Sports Agency.
- That's right.
I really give a crap,
we're really gonna do this.
You know what I'm most excited about?
We're going to force, in a decade,
every sports agent to care
more about their guys.
That's what I want my
Wikipedia entry to say.
That VaynerSports made
the entire industry
do more right by the athletes
because the competitive
bar got raised.
That's what we did.
That's what I did for the
wine business for customers
and that's what
I did for VaynerMedia
for the agency world and that's
what we're going
to do at VaynerSports.
(upbeat music)
VaynerSports y'all.
VaynerSports.
What up Equinox?
Give me the mic,
give me the mic.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] I think
the reason I am what I am
and I have what I have
and I'm as happy as I am
is because I got blessed
with big time mental health.
We've always thought about
people winning the lottery
like genetically, like, oh
you're a good looking guy.
Right, and you're good at school,
you're a handsome Harvard boy.
The shit that I actually
won on, like the thing that.
And fucking, fucking,
everyone thinks I'm
out of control like, every
time at a social event,
it's like this guy does an
enormous amount of drugs.
I've done zero.
I'm like, with all my insanity?
I'm fucking, I'm level because I'm pulling
hard in two very opposite directions.
(light music)
- I've got nothing to say.